John when Ashton joined the show you
said you knew immediately that it was
gonna work how did you know oh well
there was a there was a very clear
moment and and and ash has heard this
story before but I but you could fill in
a part that's been missing we had in the
very first episode that Ashton was in
there was a point at which he was
supposed to drop trou and be completely
naked in front of me yeah and we didn't
know how to do that in front of the live
studio audience without him actually
being naked because the whole point was
supposed to shock people and we said
well so we're gonna have to cover him up
somehow but it still has to be shocking
and everybody's trying to you know
people are going working this over in
the writers room and then Ashton pipes
in oh well I've got a huge prosthetic
penis in my trailer
and we all sort of we all had that
awkward moment of of course you do yeah
but it note what it was was everyone
sometimes you got to prop the door oh
yeah exactly so but it turns out it was
it was it was a flesh-colored under
coloured prosthetic penis but no we
thought no anime direction
yeah midsection with a Nana very
impressive anatomically correct yeah one
guy that was willing to be the mold this
is a midsection and a very realistic
it's to the thing you listed them yes a
midsection my question my questions to
why did you have this and where do I get
one you too can have one made okay so I
had this these web shorts that I did for
my company and we were producing these
various web shorts and like hidden
camera things yeah and one of the things
that we did was this sketch called naked
man and we had this guy and we had to
put on this prosthetic unit and we sent
him to interesting places while wearing
a prosthetic unit to make it look like
he was completely naked right so we sent
him to Compton and headed by ice cream
of the ice cream truck wait you said to
come tonight yes nude nude and he goes
and buys ice cream off the ice cream
truck and they're like people are
chucking chairs at him off of their
porch and it was really funny yeah not
for him less for him more for us right
and and so and then I just I was like
who knows when you're gonna need a
prosthetic penis so I kept it yeah and I
just happen to have it around you don't
throw something like that out why would
you you
[Laughter]
you